Was Ist Jetzt
Mittellos Ihnen Mass Krempelt Alles Um Aber Auch Wirklich Alles was Kann Man Eigentlich Nicht wenn die nasa Mit der Russischen Weltraumagentur Roskosmos
Gerade Einmal Eine Raumstation in die mondumlaufbahn
Bringen Will Um Verfahren für zukünftige Marsmissionen zu Testen Startet Space Sechs mal eben Direkt Zum Mars
2022 soll die erste space extrakte zum Mars Aufbrechen
2024 Dann die erste bemannte Mission wow Jetzt alle details zum science fiction Herzlich Willkommen
Wir Hatten Ja Schon in einem der letzten videos über Nachrichten vom internationalen
Astronauten Kongress in adelaide Berichtet Igor Komarow Chef der Russischen Raumfahrtbehörde Roskosmos
Hat über die Kooperation bei der mond Raumstation Deep space
Gateway Berichtet Auf Ihr und Mit ihr sollen techniken für die Landung Auf Dem Mars erprobt Werden Ihnen maske hatte Ja Schon vor Einiger Zeit
seine maß pläne verkündet der Hammer Erwin Mit 1000 Raketen Den Mars Besiedeln und
Jetzt Hat Er Seine Pläne Konkretisiert und es Wird noch
Spektakulärer Wobei er seine pläne an einem Punkt Reduziert Hat er will Kleinere Raketen Einsetzen damit Es preiswerter und
Finanzierbar Wird Statt Zwölf Metern Durchmesser Sollen sie Jetzt Wirklich Einen durchmesser von Neun Metern Aufweisen länge
48 meter Ohne Den Booster der die Rakete Antrag Das Volumen Ist Mit
Kubikmetern Größer Als Das Eines Airbus A380
Die Raketen Sind Damit größer Als Alles Was die menschen Bisher Ins all Geschossen Haben 106 meter Ist die gesamthöhe mit Den Antriebs Stufen
Deshalb Haben sie auch Einen ganz Speziellen Namen Big fucking Rocket Kurz bfr
er will die rakete in zwei Jahren Entwickeln Starb soll in der Ersten Jahreshälfte
2018 sein und Bereits
2022 sollen die Ersten zwei Bfs Bereits Ungarn zum Mars Fliegen
diese Ersten missionen Sollen dort Nach Wasser und Rohstoffen und Gefahren für Menschen Suchen
üBerhaupt Zum Mars zu Gelangen Fliegt die Bfr Erstmal in Eine erdumlaufbahn und Trifft dort Auf
Treibstofftanks die vorher in den erdorbit Geschossen Worden Sind sie sind Gefüllt Mit Methan und Sauerstoff und treiben die
Raketen Auf Dem flug Zum Mars an die Ersten Menschen die Dann
2024 zum Mars Fliegen sollen produzieren dort beim Treibstoff Für Den flug zur erde
vier Bfr sollen Dann zum Mars Fliegen Zwei Wand und zwei unbemannt Mit Diesen Flügen soll Dann die Mars Kolonie
Aufgebaut Werden die Bfs sollen Dabei Wieder Verwendbar Sein Um die Kosten Niedrig zu Halten Mit Jedem flug plant Machst Dann
100 menschen Plus fracht in 40 kabinen Zum Mars zu Fliegen die bsr Sind Zusätzlich Mit Großen Gemeinschafts Bereichen
Frachträumen und so weiter ausgestattet Alles Was man Braucht
Momentum Auch Hier Auf der erde von a Nach B zu Gelangen
und maske wäre Nicht maske Länder mit Dem Bfs Nicht auch das Reisen Nicht Auf der erde
revolutionieren wollte er will die Raketen Einsetzen Um das Reisen Auf unserem Heimatplaneten
Dramatisch zu Verkürzen Dubai New York 29 Minuten Los Angeles Toronto 24 Minuten New York Shanghai
39 minuten und so weiter und so fort Geschwindigkeit
27.000 Kilometer Pro stunde Laut Macht Kann er mit Dem Bfs Jeden ort der erde in unter Einer stunde erreichen
Das Klingt Jetzt Alles Eigentlich Vollkommen Unrealistisch Aber
Maskat Ja Schon Einiges erreicht das Springt Aber
Jetzt Wirklich Den Rahmen Wahnsinn Wenn es neues dazu gibt halte ich euch Natürlich hier bei
Pixum Auf Dem Laufenden Wenn ihr Kein video Verpassen Wollt Dann Drückt Man Hier ein Abo Aufs auge und Vergesst Nicht den
Genau Auf die glocke Denn nur Dann werdet ihr Auch Wirklich über neue videos Informiert Hier geht es Weiter Mit 1000 Raketen für maß mit
noch mehr Infos zu Mass Mars-Mission da
Besteht Gipfel Ich würde ich mal sagen also unbedingt Hier Draufklicken und Angucken und Ansonsten Bis Dann
Bleibt Dran